- [Voiceover] What I wanna
do in this video is see
if we can find the measure of angle D,
if we could find the measure of angle D
and like always, pause this video,
and see if you can figure it out.
And I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
It'll involve thinking about
how an inscribed angle relates
to the corresponding to
the measure of the arc
that it intercepts.
So, think about it like that.
All right, so, let's work
on this a little bit.
So, what do we know, what do we know?
Well, angle D, angle D intercepts an arc.
It intercepts this fairly
large arc that I'm going
to highlight right now
in this purple color.
So, it intercepts that arc.
We don't know the measure of that arc
or at least we don't know
the measure of that arc yet.
If we did know the measure of this arc
that I'm highlighting, then
we know that the measure
of angle D would just be
half that because the measure
of an inscribed angle is half the measure
of the arc that it intercepts.
We've seen that multiple times.
So, if we knew the measure of this arc,
we would be able to figure out
what the measure of angle D is.
But we do know, we don't
know the measure of that arc,
but we do know the measure of another arc.
We do know the measure of the
arc that completes the circle.
So, we do know the measure of this arc.
You might be saying,
hey wait, how do we know
that measure, it's not labeled.
Well, the reason why we
know the measure of this arc
that I've just highlighted
in this teal color is
because the inscribed
angle that intercepts it,
they gave us the information,
they said this is a 45 degree angle.
So, this is a 45 degree angle.
Then this over here is a
90 degree, 90 degree arc.
The measure of this arc is 90 degrees.
The measure of arc, I guess you could say
this is the measure of arc,
I'ma write it this way.
The measure of arc, WL.
WL is equal to 90 degrees,
it's twice that, the inscribed
angle that intercepts it.
Now, why is that helpful?
Well, if you go all the
way around the circle,
you're 360 degrees.
So, this purple arc that we
cared about, that we said hey,
if we could figure out
the measure of that,
we're gonna be able to figure
out the measure of angle D.
That plus arc, WL,
they are going to add up to 360 degrees.
Let me write that down.
So, the measure of arc, let's see,
and this is going to be a
major arc right over here.
This is so LIW,
the measure of arc LIW
plus the measure of arc WL
plus the measure
of arc WL plus this right over here.
That's going to be equal to 360 degrees.
This is going to be equal to 360 degrees.
Now, we already know
that this is 90 degrees.
We already know WL is 90 degrees.
So, if you subtract 90
degrees from both sides,
you get that the measure of
this large arc right over here,
measure of arc LIW is going
to be equal to 270 degrees.
I just took 300, I went all
the way around the circle,
I subtracted out this 90 degrees
and I'm left with 270 degrees.
So, let me write that down.
This is the measure of this
arc in purple is 270 degrees.
And now, we can figure out
the measure of angle D.
It's an inscribed angle
that intercepts that arc
so it's going to have half the measure,
the angle's going to
have half the measure.
So, half of 270
is 135 degrees and we're done,
and you might notice
something interesting,
that if you add 135
degrees plus 45 degrees,
that they add up to 180 degrees.
So, it looks like at least for
this case that these angles,
these opposite angles of
this inscribed quadrilateral,
it looks like they are supplementary.
So, an interesting question is
are they always going to be supplementary?
If you have a quadrilateral,
an arbitrary quadrilateral
inscribed in a circle,
so each of the vertices
of the quadrilateral sit on the circle.
If you have that, are opposite
angles of that quadrilateral,
are they always supplementary?
Do they always add up to 180 degrees?
So, I encourage you to think
about that and even prove it
if you get a chance, and
the proof is very close
to what we just did here.
In order to prove it, you
would just have to do it
with more general numbers like, you know,
instead of saying 45 degrees,
you could call this X,
and then you would want to
prove that this right over here
would have to be 180 minus X.
So, I encourage you to do that on your own
but I'm gonna do it in a video as well
so you can check if our
reasoning is similar.